Cities are concrete, glass and steel - they
look and act un-naturally -
absorbing heat and repelling water.
Our urban spaces are at odds with the natural
environment.
But, in parts of the German capital things
are different.
To deal with rainwater and heat, Berlin is
being transformed into what’s called a Sponge City
Carlo Becker is the architect of Berlin’s
Sponge City strategy… which harnesses rainwater
and manages heat.
In a natural ecosystem, rainwater is soaked
up by soil and vegetation,
the majority then evaporates and the rest
filters deeper into the ground.
The evaporating water then cools the surroundings.
Cities disrupt this system.
Water can’t soak through the concrete and
is piped away.
The Sponge City strategy aims to keep rainwater
where it lands, to imitate the natural water cycle.
Buildings are covered in green roofs and facades.
And down on street-level, urban wetlands and road-side
trenches - known as Swales -
filter run-off and hold water, keeping the
city cool by imitating nature.
This is Rummelsburg, in East Berlin.
Built 20 years ago, it’s become a large
scale example of the Sponge City concept.
On top we have extensive green roof of approximately
6 to 8 cm
and from there the water flows into these
courtyards here in the middle,
and underneath there is a garage.
On top of the underground garage we have a
soil layer of almost 80 cm.
It’s like a sponge and it soaks the water
during heavy rainfall
and then it's used by the plants...
so they take all the water and finally evaporate it.
Heiko Sieker is the brains behind the neighborhood’s
innovative management of stormwater.
In the whole area here we have no storm sewer
system, so no conventional pipe system.
The water flows from the road surface into
the swale and from here
it’s infiltrating into the ground.
On hot summer days, you can really feel the
coolness here, it’s much cooler compared
to other parts of the city because of the
evaporation.
You can say it’s natural air-conditioning.
Rummelsburg is just one example of a
Sponge City -
neighbourhoods across Berlin have implemented
similar initiatives.
But Berlin isn't a perfect Sponge City.
In the middle of summer 2017 the heaviest
rain in the century hit the city
submerging parts under water
and warning how much work there's still to do.
In fact, the city council has recently decided
all new developments should manage stormwater
on site, in the spirit of the Sponge City.
Climate Change is forcing Berlin and many
other cities around the world
to adapt urban environments...
transforming them to work with nature,
not against it.